hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to civilization 6 now
we got two people two friends here we've
got Victoria of the English Empire and
then we've got Harald Hardrada of the
Norwegian Empire who I'm gonna
desperately try not to make fun of but I
know I'm gonna fail so we got to see
which one of these is gonna be our
friend because I see in the agendas here
he's got an agenda as the last Viking
King and then one hidden agenda I don't
know that's good the Sun never sets so
the English want to conquer all but me I
like the English Niall of these so
there's two more people to meet we're
gonna find them and I'm gonna make the
best nation possible the best nation to
ever did see we almost got our campus
ready which is about goddamn time
because we've been waiting forever can
we do it now do we have it do we have it
there it is okay so that's good we got
the scientific capital of the world here
and hopefully that's gonna help us get
more stuff done but before we do that we
know you do we need wood like that but
we don't have time for that because I
need to make another city we gotta have
it but maybe I could just buy one no but
I don't have enough gold so screw that
we're gonna build one I mean do we
really need another city I mean probably
but do we really need another city I
mean probably but we've really need
another city ooh what's that oh cool we
can just reach her science I don't know
why that's gonna benefit anybody when
has science ever helped the world we
don't need to worry about that that's
not our problem
let's just get more cities all right
Herbert everybody go oh hey I have
traders use trip I have sent you
trailers with gifts of rune stones they
are powerful their stuns not the traders
your delegation is most welcome sorry
for mocking you
excellent oh boy it's getting worse it's
not even getting close to what it should
be and it shouldn't be any fur have an N
boy at our disposal ya can use the end
boy to gain favor with the city-state
yeah coming friendly with the city-state
neighbor can be greatly beneficial to
our civil
yeah let's do that I already know of
Lisbon let's do that
I want have Lisbon it up how do I Lisbon
can i Lisbon Lisbon Lisbon
Lisbon come on Lisbon how I send an
envoy I don't know how to do it
ah there we go I'm sending an envoy yes
confirm do it to it
hell yeah yeah forget sending envoys to
heard of Argan and Victoria we don't
need any of that we got our own and we
got our own problems here my leash we
are beginning to attract the attention
of the great people of the world rules
there are other leaders vying for their
attention too oh don't reinvent the
wheel hey hey guys the aligning guys
right people in the world we are the
wheel America is the wheel America was
number one first in making wheel maybe I
don't know well we're the best at it
it's made of stone and square it's even
better I'm gonna get uh astrology I
believe there's something else in
astrology that we need there's another
camp jeezum x' get over there under the
wildest battlemented crown pushed to a
depth of more than Sun of peace oh it's
beautiful
why do they get their turn on me or did
I discover it discovering a natural
wonder believe in astrology I'm a
Sagittarius and we're skeptical ha it's
very funny but also why didn't they
discover it considering they're very
next to it oh well i won't i won't mind
I'll just take the benefits of it who is
this anyway
oh it's you all right goodbye all the
world's a stage and all the men and
women merely players hell yeah we got
drama and poetry because if there's one
thing that teddy is it's dramatic and
poetic I don't know I think I don't know
a thing about Teddy Roosevelt at all I
think I think maybe I think maybe
markiplier is just bullshitting his way
through this I think maybe he's just
pretending to know things and then
rambling about it and hope no one
actually checks up on his [ __ ]
god damnit [ __ ] these guys the horsemen
who I have barbarians oh no I do
you better not ransack my [ __ ] because
I'm really tired of having my [ __ ]
ransacked specifically I don't like
hello
Omaha Quincy lopez swamiji parís
equipment is brilliant is you're trying
you say I have a great mind I say you
have a great beard it's wonderful it's
an honor to meet you come to Brazil do
you know how to dance Samba no it
doesn't matter you'll enjoy the carnival
regardless yes I will please I need
friends so badly all right we'll sample
that hospitality hell yeah hell yeah I
wish this guy wasn't exploring all that
way can you explore over there just go
to the ends of the earth will you
receive our diplomatic dose sure come on
down excellent I'll crush you eventually
so don't worry about it how about I will
Badou ow
what are these days these barbarians are
gonna learn something about not dying
what's that me major defeat why why are
we at a tactical disadvantage that's no
good run away into the woods oh geez
come on stop being such a little baby
get back home yeah baby right so we got
workers here finally huh they just pop
it a boat that's awesome yeah
fishing boats hell yeah crap cliff we're
gonna have crap okay so we're gonna have
crafts down there oh hello open borders
I don't you're not even in the same
place as me why would you want open bar
a fine if it makes us happier
okay thanks Victoria mm-hmm I thought
that said you have been most kind and
attractive okay well you know teddy is a
handsome male pop [ __ ]
okay thanks is that a euphemism all
right goodbye thank you maybe oh geez
hey hey whoa who are these guys who are
these guys oh it was a mistake to attack
Washington wasn't it oh we took 49
damage well that's alright you guys
fortify until healed if they do that
again they're really dumb Oh hit the
farm first and then get the crash oh
hell yes oh there's only so much to
discover and I'm afraid I can't applied
by anyone who sets out ahead of my own
explorers okay that's tough [ __ ]
Victoria Teddy's got to explore well we
whoa whoa whoa hey what do I do
what did I do why I I was nice to you
what did I do you you just complimented
mine or did you compliment your own Navy
I don't like this faced with the threat
of invasion people are ready to come up
with innovative defenses okay but I
don't feel like that was at all
necessary because why the hell did they
attack us I do not know all right so we
need to found another city up by the new
neighbors so there's still an encampment
up there so we're gonna need a little
right we're gonna need to just you know
hold our horses a little bit because we
can't leave the city cuz we're kind of
stuck so I need to make spearman whoo or
I can make heavy chariot I like that oh
I love a heavy chariot Oh hekia
okay build a farm do you create an
escort for me that's awesome
yeah creative escort formation cool nice
okay you what did you just build you
built a granary good for you
looks like we're finally getting our
heads out of our asses what are you
doing you just sleep for a bit I'll wake
you when it's ready don't worry just
fortify until healed natural history of
this archipelago is very remarkable it
seems to be a little world within itself
I am an exploration or wonder oh I don't
know what benefit that did but yay
district pillage no my campus oh come on
goddamn it these [ __ ] barbarians just
[ __ ] kill them oh you got to do
something so just hit him cuz he's
stupid a-holes keep they keep pillaging
they pillage my campus I needed that
I'll get the craft make me feel better
get the craft oh my god damn [ __ ]
why I'm gonna try this I don't know if
they'll kill you can you just fall over
and die though did you god damnit why
aren't you dead
you got like no health ah it's going to
ass I got a dude do I have enough gold
to like oh they oh they both teamed up
against me Pedro help I didn't know they
both came DUP against me this is turning
to [ __ ] why this is because I bet I bet
Victoria told Harold that I was a dick
and then they all teamed up against me
and they're all bunch of [ __ ] ah my
whole everything in Washington is
pillaged I don't know why I haven't
fixed that right fine then if you want
to be that way I'm gonna be this way I'm
going to fricken by a heavy chariot
we're gonna kick you in the dick I'm
gonna kick you in the dick we're gonna
kick you in your goddamn dick and I'll
go get my craft [ __ ] get some grass
finally ah I got the CREF I've been
craving for Jesus so this [ __ ] over
here but I got heavy zoroastrianism
where did you go you can't run from my
heavy Jerry you can exactly run from my
heavy chariot but I won't like it Earl
are coming for you hey don't run away
aren't you uh holds hold still die just
die good job you're dead okay now I'm
gonna kill these scouts cuz these Scouts
have been here forever and I haven't
taken care of them it's time to clean
house here because holy [ __ ] haven't
been doing that kill him kill him
excuse me did I run over your face with
my chariot I'm so sorry and that didn't
do nearly enough damage I need to buy
another Oh not a gold of course I am
choose a pant were a pantheon oh this
would be useful considering I have two
mines but I'm all about them fertility
rites hell yeah hell yeah oh wait was
this now I'm all about the fertility
rites oh hell yeah oh hell yeah god damn
it my city is just in ashes
Pedro buddy Pedro help please please
help I need to it's not even an option
I gotta be friendly i'ma send a
delegation we politely refused your
delegation well screw you you showed me
the wonders of Brazil I have no friends
I have no friends I might as well kill
this guy he's dead now oh well it's okay
I have no bread let's go kill some more
people oh hey hi hello pink eyes afraid
I want a shave a teacher on 12-cylinder
Eva Bergen Don Monti Mia
it's my fault yourself Viacom Kherson me
- to give out no okay uh I'll rule my
land so long as you don't try to rule my
lands as well because you seem to be
ruling
a lot of lands is Wells burgundy an
honor to meet you will you be my friend
let's be friends
because I've got a lot of enemies right
now can I have a delegation your envoy
what we arrived and I welcome them
personally our Empire could benefit to
display mercy
my last name is Fishbach so I'm German
you do like me all right okay the clear
surprise war can you be no nice to me
not war okay send a delegate ja okay
screw you fine who needs orders settler
alright fine
whoever there is not going well for me
hello we sent a diplomatic envoy to you
treat them as you would treat me the
Duke of Swabia king of burgundy king of
germany king of the romans king of Italy
and Holy Roman Emperor okay you are very
egotistical but I like that delegation
most welcome where's my chariot you go
over here mysticism fine let's do a
mysticism yeah we got another chariot
hooray we're gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
everybody are you wait there you wait
there Bubba you wait there baby boom mmm
cuz I need to oh it's repairing well
doesn't ok that's at least good it
repairs itself oh no wait I need to
repair it god damn it ah fine I'll
repair it Jesus Jesus oh hello open
borders of course maybe I should have
accepted open borders for the air
Victoria okay
von der Ville indeed are you gonna be my
friend now can I send you a delegation
delegation oh come on don't be so stingy
cool man be cool about the I'm friends
with frederick barbarossa he's my friend
okay never mind never mind okay no
friends okay we're not friends I just
shouted that from the rooftops for no
reason but okay I guess we're just not
friends that's how it goes Germany has
progressed from classical era to the
medieval era wow I am I'm lagging behind
then one man's magic yay the man's
engineering yay we got engineering it's
about damn time took me a long time but
I finally got it can I get this major
defeat oh don't tell me chariots are bad
against that ah no oh I suck so much
dick
oh god I'm the worst Oh No
what have I done there's spearmen of
course they're good against horses oh
wow my cities are in ruin and I've done
horrible things
can you change your production please to
shift all of that towards like a spear
man huh we've done bad heaven we we've
done very bad haha what are you gonna do
no huh what are you gonna do now oh you
have no city to fortify yourself it's
still very bad for me to attack you but
what are you gonna do now ah this was a
bad idea wasn't it okay it's a bad idea
all right so you Baltimore you're
basically screwed so why not make a
builder instead of doing something that
could actually protect you I don't know
oh god oh no oh no my porch area my poor
guy oh he ain't do so good I mean he did
better on the defensive than he did on
the offensive so I guess that's good you
just fortify there can you uh you go
tack that guy Ruby and then leave
Baltimore defenseless yeah that's that's
what I should have done but what I was
doing is I was opening it up so I could
buy like a warrior then I got him and
he's defending the city
oh I'm spending all my gold because I'm
an idiot yeah yeah I'm an idiot
yeah or [ __ ] haha oh god the whole
chariot just exploded Oh No
well kill these douchebags heaven ski
good job Baltimore yeah sure did it you
did it and I'm proud of you you did it
good I can't wait to see what you're
gonna do again also I forgot I'm at war
Germany denounced the evil deeds of
Norway
yay go Germany go all right that's my
buddy Germany don't mind as I kill this
poor defenseless Scout he deserved it
he was an a-hole oh hello I will destroy
my enemies and if you continue to help
them I will destroy you as well I didn't
help nobody I was helping I only help
you good buddy Frederick I love you so
he's unfriendly with Pedro but Peter was
a dick to me anyway so you know I I
don't I don't wanna
oh no he's unfriendly with me oh no way
no okay I want to be friend would this
make him happy if I denounced Pedro
Pedro rejected me so [ __ ] you Pedro this
situation is going to get worse before
it gets any better
oh really or you upset about that Pedro
oh I'm sorry
oh what a dick - don't do good Frederick
Frederick - telly do good
did Teddy goo you do good Frederick did
did you good could i didnäôt job these
guys will make peace I'd like to make
peace sup that possible can we make
peace make this deal more to go make
peace cannot accept this deal well okay
how about you give me gold and we make
peace that's a good option I look third
opsin
alright fine goodbye goodbye I'm gonna
laugh when it's Gandhi behind the scenes
has been manipulating all this son of a
[ __ ] eree okay just explore kill
anybody you see blah blah blah okay we
got another chariot which is not exactly
what we needed but okay we need more
builders Oh a machine todas las conchas
aserp rien dainty's gas mint is
brilliant is that jnanis oh hell he's
our own okay did you just come here to
brag dude because honestly I don't care
I've denounced you your douche although
that Norwegian fella did say something
similar before he attacked me I better
go nuclear right now who Envoy I'm gonna
max out Lisbon because I need money
which means that I need other stuff too
now Manny it just sucks I'm not where I
want to be because I was set back so
much by freaking barbarians and then
everyone wants to kill me
only Frederick's
friend and Fredriksson [ __ ] everyone
knows that no one more [ __ ] Isha's
Gandhi [ __ ] oh that doesn't look good
is that England stuff maybe you should
kill them huh what are you doing what
are you doing there you wanna you wanna
fight
ha Bethke I don't get it uh take that
England ah we shot a few arrows at you
and you you hurt real bad
yeah that's right oh yeah we go get you
again ha take that England we don't like
you you declared war on us now declare
war on the ocean yeah you better run
away all right who wants some you want
some you want some hey you're gonna get
some yeah that's right hip yeah that's
what you get you can't beat my ships
well you can probably beat my ships very
easily because my ships aren't doing
exactly a whole lot but anyway you know
it's a principle of the thing
my builder can you fix these fricked up
improvements whoa jeez what was that hit
him hit him hard
nice how about you get promoted
um yeah combat Sphinx hell yeah hit him
hard okay go over there fix that
improvement you know oh [ __ ] I should
have just put one down there why didn't
anything I'm an idiot
ooh natural philosophy would be great
yes please
yes please okay build a quarry oh good
finally well the pasture man I'm just
beating the [ __ ] out of this one thing
here oh it's dead
oh no England what are you gonna do was
that Carthage oh [ __ ] is that Carthage
is thing god dammit ah did I screw up
bad oh no I didn't mean to hit Carthage
Carthage is just an innocent city-state
what I was trying to beat up England I'm
a bad man oh well whatever
boink yeah boink and hittin there we are
England hit them hit them hard
yeah England you like that I don't think
you do Teddy Roosevelt don't take no
[ __ ] from nobody um where they go did
they run away like little babies yes
they did oh ow ow owie that didn't hurt
at all
it hurt almost exactly none okay never
mind then we're just gonna keep carrying
on don't mind us
sorry Carthage you stay cool Carthage
you're cool Carthage you I build up
brand lambdaj back rubber and we got
silk now right does that mean we have
soaked that better mean we have sick
little if we don't have silk I'm gonna
be very pissed
ow ow ow no it hurts so badly doesn't
need to die oh yeah that's starting to
get hopeless I'm gonna have them get out
of there well I'm baby Devin - but oh
how you got one of my ships will rebuild
it when we fortify land he'll I don't
know if they can do that but oh well
whatever Ari we don't have enough damage
going on there so just get back home
somehow oh look at all that crap oh look
at all that crap I want that graph what
are you doing who are you
Norway Norway I don't like that Norway
you stay out of there Norway you stay
away from mine anders norway norway
ain't gonna take my nanners my Nana's
are my neighbours
no urine handers goddamn he's got me
cornered here buddy's gonna die
nonetheless what cause he takes serious
norwegian pillaged what now when did the
Norwegian bastards do that [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you and all you do [ __ ] you I can't even
get my gali out of there but [ __ ] you
can I hit that guy yeah yeah him hit him
hard oh damn it offensive tactic okay
anyway I'm all out of time for this one
things are gonna heat it here but maybe
someday we could make peace you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] with your stupid
face in your ugly ass beard and your
weird clothes and funny accent you and
your dumb helmet with it it's too small
for your stupid head let's make peace
buddy let's make peace come on man
my little L live a little oh man
Nate no you about about fifty gold
150 hunted toy fat never mind I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up nonetheless yes
stupid poop all right so anyway I'm all
out of time I'm really loving this game
like I remember why I really like this
game because it's super duper it just
it's just enjoyable it's just something
that's like a worthwhile endeavor Oh
what is that over there okay cool but
either way that is all the time that I
have available for now I am nowhere near
getting any great people so anyway
that's all good for them they've they've
already got a bunch of great people I
didn't get any great people why have I
not wait what was I supposed to try to
do this oh I see I've been being dumb
oh I'm an idiot
I'm not doing anything of here well
alright then oopsie-doopsie
wasn't focusing on nothing I'm doing
terribly World Rankings ah I'm in fifth
place I'm in sixth place I'm in fourth
place I'm gonna like okay so anyway I'm
doing terribly but as I said I was
supposed to be doing terribly so I don't
know if I want to do any more videos of
this this was a lot of fun it take a
long long time for me to even finish
this game and I'd probably just lose
anyway so thank you everybody so much
for watching I really hope you enjoyed
this I had a lot of fun with it hope you
did too
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]